[Music]
great to be here with you today thank
you so much for having me of course so
talk to me about what exactly your
company does yeah so I'm one of the
co-founders and CEO of a company called
patch okay at patch our core objective
is to scale carbon dioxide removal with
software okay carbon dioxide removal is
a core ingredient to fighting climate
change so when you think about
mitigating the climate crisis there's
two core levers you have to pull the
first is decarbonizing that looks like
rolling out renewable electricity
electrifying vehicles but then the
second piece is removing carbon from the
atmosphere we've been polluting for the
last 150 years and we actually have to
undo some of that pollution in addition
to preventing further pollution in order
to hit our climate goals now how did you
get the idea for this walk me through
your founding story yeah absolutely so I
initially studied chemical engineering
AB aill with the intention of working in
low carbon energy it's how I thought I
was going to fight the climate crisis it
didn't work out I only got got jobs in
oil and gas coming out of school and so
instead of doing that I worked at a wide
variety of tech startups for around
eight or nine years and then back in
April of 2020 me and my co-founder Aaron
grunfeld really wanted to start
something of our own and so what we did
was we looked at what are the eight or
nine things that need to be true in
order for us to hit our climate goals
going back to those Solutions I
mentioned earlier so renewable energy
Agriculture and carbon dioxide removal
was one of those elements where it felt
like there was no infrastructure to get
it off the ground and we had very little
existing Capac back in 2020 we weren't
even doing one 1000 of the amount of
carbon dioxide removal we need to be
doing and so we decided to focus on that
area and understand how we could apply
the software skills we learned in past
companies we've worked up before and
apply it to carbon diet removal very
cool now talk to me about your
fundraising Journey how's that been for
you yeah thankfully it's gotten easier
and easier you know the first round we
raised around $4 and half million dollar
from inre but that took a really long
time that was during CO as well from
guess that was June or June or July of
202 so big big kind of drawn out
experience but we've been fortunate
enough to raise from a really wide
variety of folks including andreon cotu
and energize and have raised around $80
million today dat so really thankful
it's to be really well capitalized
particularly in this more economic
uncertain time so we're just heads down
focused on building and doing what's
best for carbon markets as a whole now I
want to get some sort of a sense of
scale of your company can you talk to me
a bit about how many users you have or
anything like that that'll show me your
size yeah absolutely so on the buyer
side of the equation we work with around
400 corporates companies as large as eqt
or Bandon company to a smaller startups
you haven't heard of before and then on
the supply side we work with around a
hundred or so carbon credit developers
at various stages of scale as well so we
have around 400 million tons under
management in the patch platform
holistically unfortunately I feel like
climate change is just so politicized
right now what's your experience been
like running a startup in kind of a
politically fractured industry yeah you
know the the policy world is actually
very new to me I'm coming from kind of
engineering and then Tech and so I'm
spending way more time in DC than I
initially thought I would have been you
know I think the biggest thing to
understand is you have to think of these
problems in terms of systems and
everyone has a slightly different
priority set and you know you can bucket
it as right or the left in the US but
the reality of the situation is all
these kind of Global Systems whether
it's kind of climate change energy Food
Systems Economic Development or job
creation are all Interlink and so in a
lot of time a lot of cases it's all
about just reframing a particular
problem so that people are excited so a
great example is the IRA the inflation
reduction Act is the biggest climate
change bill ever passed in North
American history and what got it over
the ledge was in many cases the job
creation element right how do we create
Great American paying jobs that catalyze
kind of climate Solutions so kind of of
the right in a lot of cases get what
they need where they really want to have
Economic Development and maybe in some
in some cases kind of more economic
growth right but on the left case they
actually get the climate change
solutions they want so all about the
compromise it's all about finding that
win-win in a lot of cases what's the
kind of 1 plus one equals three exactly
and finally what would you like your
legacy to be yeah so I mean when I think
about my legacy or or patch generally I
think the biggest thing is just putting
a dent in climate change you know we
need to be removing around 10 to 15
gigatons per year by 2050 yeah and if we
can be doing you know five 10 15% and
actually attribute that to what patch is
doing I think that's really
[Music]
exciting